all right so real quick I have to catch
a plane and I have like 10 minutes which
means all of you in line are [ __ ] so
the current state of entrepreneurship is
in an interesting spot I think it's an
amazing time at the same token and an
awkward time for me because I'm really
fearful like I'm not about
entrepreneurship I'm about all of you
deploying self-awareness and figuring
yourself out because that is always
gonna be the path that gets you to a
happy place quickest this pedestal that
entrepreneurship is on right now is
weirdly dangerous because it's making a
lot of people start businesses that
ultimately won't be successful and
actually can put them in a pretty tough
spot
so my ambition here is not for all of
you to go home and start your own
business my ambition is for all of you
to understand why I'm so happy and it's
because I figured myself out at a young
age on the back of the DNA ridiculously
good parenting and circumstance of my
environment and that's what this is all
about what what entrepreneurship is
about is putting yourself in a position
to succeed you know I think my strengths
which have created my up this this
narrative are I have really good natural
intuition and understanding of human
behavior so I think that I've understood
consumer behavior and where it's going
in the internet I think I'm running a
marathon so I'm extremely patient which
i think is a huge factor I think that uh
my work ethic you know I'm just my
actions match my ambition and and I
would say probably my lack of fear of
failing you know I think it's more
important to learn and fail than to
always be right mainly on the back of
not worrying about what other people
think I think those are some of the core
ingredients that really
me right and I think the ultimate way to
put yourself in a position to succeed is
to deploy self-awareness so as fun as
this is gonna sound and it's hyped up as
we all are and this is a ridiculous vibe
and a beautiful setting and the Energy's
off the charts I really really want to
set the tone and like bring it down a
notch to practicality because I want you
to win and winning comes in a million
different forms but it starts with being
happy and you will always lose when you
try to force something
and so again back that's being
self-aware you need to know yourself do
you love getting punch to the face doing
the stomach for it and the truth is it's
not cool
it feels cool right now but it's not
cool it's just a personality trait
with a plug just laying in Tampa has
little in-and-out trip for iris and I it
is 2:40 p.m. so we're back here at the
airport it like seven or eight like so
quick little flight but something that's
emerged in the last three or four days
for me that I'm gonna start building on
top of them on and I wanted to interrupt
these regularly scheduled programs of
the vlog and ran to you a little bit
that's about kindness it has become very
apparent to me as I could continue to
dissect like why the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
working for me and how do I get it to
work for you
kindness is foundational for me you know
it is absolutely a core tenet and it
delivers unbelievable dividends in
business but more importantly like I
just I don't know why winning in
business or being an alpha or trying to
make something happen
I'll be right with you have just given
my rant on kindness is not associated
with kindness enough and I just am
desperate for everybody watching this to
start understanding how much kindness is
part of this equation
it just works it feels good it may not
come natural to you but you need to
dissect it and understand it and more
importantly if you haven't especially if
you're a tough dude you need a triple
[ __ ] down on it cuz it works
period end of story let's go virus let's
go
[Music]
Chatterjee was the villain
right now we're going to the hole like I
just want to do my own thing but at the
same time you have this pressure on the
stickler that you have to go out and get
a job from suicide societies doesn't
have a face so that should be easy to
navigate but it's also the time
management alright like should I invest
a lot of time in my side hustles but I'm
also doing stuff for school let me give
you some that we really let me give you
something that really [ __ ] matters
it actually doesn't matter what you do
in all of your 20s if you have too much
time to correct it in your 30s if you
actually understood that it doesn't
[ __ ] matter there is no right or
wrong answer
everything gets me [ __ ] I mean that
I'm not saying it to be like I'm saying
it cuz it doesn't feel that way because
you're letting you're letting other
voices into your head you value other
people's opinions more than you value
your euro and that's 99 for some people
that's not like you suck that's what you
have to start thinking about because
when you're 87
then you don't have time now you have
the best asset with everything I've got
I will trade with you three [ __ ]
right now I'm being dead [ __ ] serious
for everything I've got I'll take the 22
years back times the [ __ ] ass that
broke
you have people leave it I believe it
and this is another question I have
because it's relevant the time how do
you optimize your time when it takes a
pass is what you're doing it personally
yep when you have time as your asset
you shouldn't overstressed optimizing it
which is why I'm like [ __ ] off in your
20s because that's your biggest asset it
become like it's the leverage where you
have a spine like to me it's kind of
like you know I talked a lot about macro
and micro that's like doing things in
parallel right so like every day I go
home but at the highest stuff on
patience like I'm much more worried
about you like [ __ ] around I'm like
from 9:00 like from 7:00 a.m. to
midnight today but not doing behavior
that worries about it at the macro I'm
worried about you watching an hour okay
dumb TV interesting first of all
everything best to map your ambition
so first of all with the [ __ ] Russian
because like if you wanna be like
wealthy and live a good quality life it
actually doesn't take that much to work
for making $200,000 years of
unbelievably high quality like holidays
everybody now is thinking in like
millions and hundreds everybody thinks
you're gonna build in future a value
great value you can be done right now
meaning like meaningful value like this
to me like massive like well then if
you're if you want masses and if you
want to really impact like what I'm up
to
has been [ __ ] 15 hours a day for 22
years in a row giving up all sorts of
[ __ ] leisure and fun
it's just about understanding
self-awareness but the biggest thing is
putting over pressure in the short-term
is a bad [ __ ] move
it's a badly it leads to it leads for
short-term behavior
you end up doing short-term decisions
Chris Tingley left vaynermedia for
$3,000 more in salary because they
wanted to move out of their place
I've been following you before you
take the one give me the most patients
marry like a force repaired some points
of view of course you want to see how
you size up to your homies
like compared to my whole new for like
20s I was the loser I worked on my dad
hookers
like if he was like it was like yo I got
a internship at Facebook I cool like I
don't know like what might make your mom
proud maybe for that kid and maybe it
does yeah like it's gotta be binary
Tampa what is up if I could if I could
use the attention right now to say one
thing please deploy self-awareness you
don't have to be an entrepreneur you
don't have to be anything actually what
you need to try to do with all your
might is go inside your head and
understand who you are and not apologize
for it and that really matters to me I
just want to thank you guys so much for
all the good vibes I hope I hope you
come over and check out the talk I'm
about to give but I actually weirdly
rather you go back home and [ __ ]
hustle on your own [ __ ]
[Applause]
Oh
thank you so much that's good no it's
really real I'm a little sick so I'm
gonna get it okay don't worry hi how are
you such a pleasure thank you so much
for real for real
basically they know but it's been really
you're really helping thanks but like
you're making an impact thank you um I'm
just gonna call you like specialist in
okay I can't sign three books for me for
the Chinese team you got it all right so
you're gonna be meeting with white rhino
on march 19th yes and they are a digital
company that goes that spreads message
is about what foreigners feel like
living in China yes
okay so Roz's team and his content
producers and the audience has a few
questions for you
the first question is why do you want to
enter in the Chinese market when you
already have such a huge following on
the Western market because my ambition
is great you know like the truth is I
have very big ambitions and you know in
my lifetime it will be the number one
global market in the world it is the
number one global mark in the world
that's hard for Americans who've had
that throne for a long time but there
are so many people that I want to reach
and and the thought of not being in the
mainland China is just unacceptable okay
thank you
[Music]
yep about to give a speech and that's
all I have to say
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you phone thuds baby
[Applause]
let's go guys you're you're freaking out
the people that don't know me here's
what's up
this internet thing it's real and and
and the reason I go there I need you
guys all to listen very carefully
everybody including me is under
estimating how big this internet thing
is we got so lucky and we're also a
little bit screwed a lot of you in 30 40
50 years are gonna look back at this
year and be like [ __ ] how good we had it
I didn't get it and I'll tell you what I
mean by that the reason I was able to
build my dad's business from a three to
a sixty million dollar business like
that was because of the internet I would
have done it I would have had 15 liquor
stores I would have done it but it
wouldn't have been done that way and
definitely not at that speed this thing
is so guys this is a more powerful
computer in your pocket right now then
President Reagan had running the [ __ ]
free world everything's about
distribution and what you put in it do
you know how crazy it would be to wake
up tomorrow and not have the internet
you like you just sit like you wouldn't
know what to do this is now where we
live this is now secondary to this you
may not like it you may think it's weird
but it's the truth and it will play out
and guess what a lot of things have
happened to the human race like we
struggle in putting things into context
because you take for granted what you
have
like documenting the process huge yeah
bro could you imagine if with how many
people here vlogging let's go yeah baby
could you imagine if we were lucky
enough that vlogging has been around for
50 years and we could have seen all the
people that we think are incredible just
see their process of coming up the game
more importantly back to every damn day
my man whether you make it or you don't
the fact that your great-great grandkids
are gonna be able to watch that film is
unbelievable
it's I I didn't get to know either one
of my grandfather's they both died right
before I got to know them like you know
cool it would be to have all that film
on them so you might be thinking about
blogging as like narcissistic and
somebody's being a charlatan you're
[ __ ] short-sighted if you're not
blogging you're taking something very
special away from your future family
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
okay Gary yes oh my gosh thank you thank
you for some blow bye guys can I get a
virus picture real quick okay
[Music]
see ya bye guys thank you for my one
life use something about it
thank you
[Music]
[Music]